[Music]
what can i do for you
i want to build a house these are some
of the vacant sites that you have
you see if you lend me the money and let
me use a site
then i could have that built for me and
my kids i'm really sorry
i can't help you with this
[Music]
we can't go on like this just keep
telling yourself
it's temporary sorry guys
like three times and you got your kids
here john please we need this job
what are we doing sandra i think this is
good for the girls
i've seen a counsellor
[Music]
you know i know but there are some
people you just
can't i have designed a house
that costs just 35 000 euros to build
sandra
why didn't you ask me your mother was
far more than a cleaner to me
she was a friend it's land going to
waste
use it build a house for you and your
girls
our own house at the bottom of the
garden like a fairy house
[Music]
need hands for a few weekends over the
summer if you want help
[Music]
sandra oh my god
are you going to see her she's not
herself she wants to stay with me
you're looking to me sandra scully
you've been served
breach of access i'm sorry love but
legally he has a right to go to court
what is the point of a house if i have
no kids to put in it
most of us get so sunk in our own pain
we don't notice our children's
but you did and that makes you a good
you all know mother he did to me and
that you still bring me in here and you
ask me
questions like why didn't you leave him
would you never ask why didn't he stop
[Music]
you